said what change or changes in the film
industry would have to happen to get you
back to producing movies again I'm still
producing movies and I plan to keep
producing movies for another 40 years
but I'm producing movies now I love out
of passion not just because I'm
producing my wife's movie I'm producing
some other films too but because they
don't want to make the compromises that
come when you earn your living
producing films what I'm tremendously
excited about what I think is a really
phenomenon of this year of 2014 is that
I think for the first time we as an
industry as a filmmaking community have
the capacity and the understanding to
look at what a full film ecosystem
rebuild would do when we talk about
managing complexity I think that you can
see how we've improved the process in
filmmaking an individual strategy for a
film and how we bring it to Festival
bring it to market maneuver through the
distribution mechanism but we've always
only been thinking about it on an
individual basis right and now we're
able to look at all the different
stakeholders that if they're out there
see what their needs are to see what the
repercussions might be the wind falls
and the pitfalls might be for them and
to start to say what will that look like
what would a rebuild of the ecosystem
look like and the core thing there is
it's not just how to get your movie made
it's not just about how to get your
movie made and how to get your movie
seen it's about how to get your movie
made seen and compensated fairly like
those are key tenants if we want to
maintain
particularly here in America our status
is the most robust diverse film culture
and film industry in the globe we have
to say we need to make sure that our
artists and their supporters are
compensated fairly you know that when
somebody earns a start-up size a VC
return on their movie when someone can
hold on to their IP and benefit from its
future iterations down the road and be
able to say look okay those folks who
that invested in Facebook earned X times
multiple but these folks who invested in
my film or my body of work also earned a
similar multiple I'll be happy to say
that that's how I'm going to earn my
living again you know that that we need
the best thing that we can do as a film
culture as a film industry is make sure
that investors earn risk appropriate
returns on their money we need to create
a sustainable investor class we need to
recognize it's a four legged table right
it needs all legs to stand strong the
artists the audience the the industry
and the the investors the financial
supporters we need to look out for all
side of those to have a strong
foundation that we can build a great
culture out that will make a good meal
you